well Kavita I arrived in Chicago two
days ago to to to spend three months at
The Institute of politics and and I
thought that as soon as I get here I
might get a relief from all that the
harassment that that has been inflicted
on me but today when I opened the
newspapers I saw the Indian foreign
minister give an interview in Washington
DC that Publications like the Washington
Post are running a propaganda against
the Indian government in the west and he
uh in as many words pointed out to my my
writings in the Washington Post as an
opinion writer so that's that's the top
most officer and this is just an
everyday
um uh everyday part of my life just
before I was leaving for Chicago a
course summon was issued to me in a in a
about an investigative story that I did
in 2008 about Hindu nationalists and
their and their involvement in Terror
attacks uh the complaint by the Hindu
nationalist against me says that my
journalism is influenced by my faith and
the court has initiated proceeding
things against me in that case 16 years
later just as I was about to leave this
is just a very small window into the
world of the harassment that I have
faced multiple multiple
um Publications have have researched
about the kind of threats that I
received 8.5 million tweets registered
against me in three months uh emerging
out of India calling me a Jihadi Jain my
my image morphed on a pond video
circulated all over the Internet
um alleged photoshops with photoshops
with leaders of the opposition
photoshops with critics of the
government saying I have sexual
relationships with people my bank
accounts Frozen for Relief work that I
did for covid-19 victims as Persians
cast on my Integrity there is not a
single thing that exists in the Playbook
of the government that has not been used
against me or my family members stopped
at the airport from flying out of India
to speak about freedom of speech and
democracy so every day
I pay a course that nobody really knows
and a cause that I do not speak about to
the world because I feel that I do not
have to make myself the story but
unfortunately uh in in modi's India I am
the hunted and the hunter God knows I
mean this is what they say a lot of
times but I do feel I do feel that I
some days it gets exhausting but that's
the life I've chosen for myself and
that's the India we are living in where
this where those who bear witness to the
to the India story every day are being
targeted relentlessly some of our best
activists and journalists are behind
bars Muhammad zubair was behind bars for
almost a month for a tweet for an
innocuous tweet that he put out five
years ago about a film for that he was
behind bars for at least one month gauri
lankish a journalist was murdered by
allegedly by Hindu nationalists outside
her house and gory had
translated my book Gujarat files in
kannada language and we were supposed to
do a book launch in Karnataka of Gujarat
files with her and she was killed weeks
before that so this is an everyday life
of people who choose to speak sapura
zargar a journalist sorry an activist
from from from Jamia she was pregnant
when she was arrested and today
um a few weeks ago her degree from her
PhD degree has been canceled by Jamia
Amelia islamia it surprised each one of
us is paying and we continue to pay
and is that why the media in India that
the kind of
for the large part don't report on the
kinds of stories that you are reporting
from is there a self-censorship going on
well I feel a lot of people say that the
media in India is ideologically bankrupt
they are bigoted but I feel that the
media in India is actually quite
opportunist they are people who want to
save their jobs there are people who
want to bask in the in in the favors
lent by the government of the day these
are people who
um who are happy to dog whistle against
a 220 million Muslim population as long
as they get promotions in their
respective jobs and then these are the
very editors and mainstream Publishers
who will reach out to me saying Rana you
don't have loans to pay but we have
loans to pay and we have to look our
children my question to them is if you
had loans to pay then why be a witness
why be journalist in a country like
India whose story needs to be told to
the world Mr Modi brought more than 10
cheetahs on his birthday which was
drummed down as some kind of an
achievement and I I can tell you there
was a there was a caption and a leading
News Channel India by the India Today
group that says share cheetah and the
lion has got the cheetahs and I mean
it's nauseating it is nauseating to the
uh you know to see the extent to which
the mainstream media is not just being
compromised but it's being used as a
tool to extend the government's hate
politics against Muslims and minorities
but not a single question I mean in an
Ideal World the media in India should be
asking Narendra Modi it's been he's been
in power since 2014. we are the world's
largest democracy the prime minister of
India has not taken a single press
conference or a single question from a
journalist in an Ideal World Media would
have you know asked him and took him and
media would have you know asked these
raging questions but we see the the
India that we live in we see mainstream
media asking questions of the critics
asking questions of the opposition uh
Indian media news channels spent three
days of prime time debates on me and my
family whether we are corrupt whether we
had evaded taxes I mean that's the media
that we are right now consuming
I mean how do you stay objective given
everything that you've been through you
are a journalist after all how do you
keep that objectivity
honestly I think Kavita objectivity is a
myth that journalism journalists need to
do away with because objectivity does
not allow us to define the oppressor and
the oppressed uh though in especially in
the scenario that we are dealing with
where every the media feels compelled to
talk about this false equivalence about
this and that we are dealing at it we
are looking at a scenario for instance
the the Delhi anti-muslim riots uh when
when President Trump ex-president Trump
came to India and he was in Delhi
violence broke out against Muslims
following Mr modi's leader giving this
provocative you know a a statement that
traitors should be shot dead traitors of
course the insinuation was against
Muslims
um so how do you remain objective when
on one side you have the state
Administration ministers cabinet police
Judiciary and on the other other side
you have the marginalized the Muslims
and dalits against whom these uh you
know these powers are being used and at
a time like this you see the media doing
the false equivalence you know
um I don't think there's space for
objectivity in time of authoritarianism
and at a time when Muslims in India are
almost at the verge of ethnic cleansing
I don't see objectivity as As a matter
of pride in fact I S I desire that we
identify the oppressor from the
oppressed and that's something it's not
just about India it's globally uh when
we when we as journalists report from a
country it is it is disheartening to um
to talk about India but I think I
and I won't deny that I mean when I say
my muslimness it's my lived experience I
cannot deny my lived experience in my
writings and my report does that mean
um they start me I discriminate against
the Hindu majority I don't think if if
the Indian if the Indians who criticize
my reporting of Mr modi's politics where
to just go back five years ago and see
my reportage of the Congress ruled uh
UPA government of eight years and and
and the targeting of dalits and adivasis
and the backward classes in India then
they would not be leveling these
allegations
how has social media changed the media
landscape yeah I'm talking about in
terms of reporting communal tensions
because I I know you've talked about
social media being democratizing but
it's also been used by Modi uh with his
new powers to oversee social media
platforms to regulate inflammatory
rhetoric which could be argued to shut
down uh some voices
oh well when I said it's a democratic
space so at a time when independent
journalists are being silenced by the
Modi government and they are resorting
to writing blogs and tweeting about
what's happening on the ground so it is
a space where in the absence of
Gatekeepers we are able to tell the
truth that the mainstream media is not
telling India having said that the
Twitter has taken on the Indian
government has taken the Indian
government to code because the Indian
government has asked Twitter to take
down tweets by journalists including me
so there is an attack on Twitter as well
having said that uh while in the absence
of gatekeeper there is also this fear
and we as a legit fear that we face
every day where a Lynch Mob a virtual
Lynch Mob attacks us on a daily basis to
an extent that
um I mean it it is it is overwhelming it
is overwhelming and intimidating because
you go on Twitter every word that you
say is being is being used against you
and and this platform with this Twitter
Facebook WhatsApp is now used as a tool
by the government a tool of propaganda
so yes there are fact Checkers in India
who do fact checking but by the time of
fake news is used to Target dissenters
and journalists like me their fake news
spreads faster than the fact checked
news that later goes on we saw what's
happened in London during the communal
situation in London between Hindus and
Muslims the growth that disinformation
played as rightly put out by a BBC story
about the role disinformation played in
in triggering the communal tension um in
in London where the same situation has
prevailed in India where Hindu
nationalism along with disinformation
has played a crucial part in labeling us
as the enemies of the state the kind I
mean I have done this experiment some
days I just put a full stop on my
Twitter I don't even tweet anything just
one full stop and I'll get a thousand
replies Jihadi Jain where's your burqa
where is hijab I mean so basically it's
not it's not they're not they are not
opposing or criticizing what I say these
are people who are there who have been
made to see me as An Enemy of the State
an enemy of Hindus in a country where 82
percent or 80 percent Indian Hindus are
being made to feel like victims in their
own country
um so we end up becoming the collateral
damage we the storytellers we the truth
tellers we the people who are bearing
witness are are the ones who have to pay
this price offline and online